the gyro can experience he used to say
that you likes your Porsche to go to the
comedy store because it like juiced you
up you still feel like that you know
like I liked something loud something
that's just stupid yeah so I'm try to
get the zone yeah but it just gives you
like a little bit of a just like a
kickstart yeah you don't have to drive
fast it's not about that it's about what
it can do it's like you're taking it out
for this like it just moves better moves
around corners better its grips the road
better it feels more more my can yeah my
911 is kind of like that but in its
actually got the the elements of like a
baja truck also so you could just
[ __ ] smash speed bumps and like you
know those weird transitions into
driveways here that everybody hates in
sports cars you're gonna take on an
angle and all that yeah boom straight in
on the power just kind of bounce it a
little bit you could drive off a curbs
and [ __ ] it is so fun it's all those
things you love about your car but also
the things you want in like a trophy
truck Jesus Christ rules so great you
should be a Salesman
I am no I don't get kickbacks but but
you should everybody should buy an
off-road Porsche it's flat right larious
yeah of all the recommendations a lot of
people out there consumer interests you
stay in school and get your [ __ ]
together
Jordan peterson says to clean your room
dude you don't want to come at me for
good consumer sorry Porsche you buy some
stupid [ __ ] I only have stupid cars I
love the fact you dump so much money to
that Mustang because like that's the no
no disrespect that's okay it's true is
the second ugliest version it's it was
kind of unique at the time yeah wasn't
ugly in the UN Rutledge spent mad time
talking [ __ ] about my muscle and it's
just an odd choice cuz you you're a
connoisseur of automobiles right like
mum in my mind I'm like why wouldn't he
get like a 68 Mustang I don't have a
connection to those cars you know yeah I
was I was I was born in 81 so I so to me
the Mustangs of my youth were that was
my car larry chen shot that photo
doesn't read oh um oh the car was
beautiful man that was a beautiful car
I did dump a lot of money into it but I
turned I got on the cover of Car Craft
magazine I had a speech feature in speed
hunters and I and I got all my money
back out of it even after I gave half
the money to charity no I got out of it
pretty good it's fantastic and you
deserve very petrol it drove really nice
to look at this the suspension like the
way it sits rather the Rio that the fat
wide tires the right stance those are
awesome yes - what are those wheels the
wheels are HR e RS 105 s which is a
really popular wheel for the Ford GT
they use this so that's probably the
cheapest car they've ever been the side
picture the wheels the retail for like
12 K they're really expensive yeah yeah
pretty yeah I mean I'm sure if joe rogan
wanted a deal we could probably get
something worked out with HR e but
that's so that car was so cool but you
know after it was done like that picture
you just saw is it done basically and
once it was done I was like oh [ __ ] man
you know this thing handles so good and
it looks so cool it could really use
like 300 more horsepower like it was
like it was like 300 horsepower 350
horsepower and it really needed to be
like 600 and so I was at the point where
I either was gonna spend two more years
and 20 more thousand dollars and maybe
I'd be happy with what I got at the end
or it was just time to move on and at
about the same time I drove Lee Keane is
the name of the dude who built my
Porsche and he builds and sells those -
number fourteen of the cars he builds I
drove his for a video and I just was so
in love with it and I just said oh this
is exactly the thing that I need in my
life right now and so when I sold the
Mustang I gave the money leaking and got
a lifted 911 let's look at some words I
took that as your daily driver yeah why
don't I love in combination with the
scooter and the test cars I have but
that's hilarious
yeah you're number one squeeze yes
Safari 911 from 1987 I didn't spend all
that money to look at it you know yeah
yeah yeah right if you if I spent all
that money it has no collector value
right it's just the value is what I get
out of driving isn't it shock
when you open one of those old Porsches
the the heft to it the the surprising of
solidness yes yes I mean those those
galvanized Porsche bodies from the 60s
to the mid-90s are some of the finest
built vehicles in terms of quality and
engineering they're not they're
expensive to maintain they can be
annoying but as far as pure quality of
engineering there's there's nothing
better yeah it's probably the finest car
in the world from a quality perspective
through most of its life
yeah the 964 is a really unusual one for
me because that year was like they still
kept the frog eyes yeah but the
suspension became more more lively a
little bit more controllable but yet it
still maintained a lot of the old feel
yeah well at the time those cars if you
go back to 92 when those cars came out
or 91 and you read sort of the
contemporary reviews of the car they
were calling it old slow and heavy you
know they said it was a solid feeling
car but the Corvette zr1 was way faster
and lighter you know what I mean and
yeah and the Ferrari let's see that well
the 348 was a piece of [ __ ] but the [ __ ]
hell's 92 some of the Japanese stuff the
Supra the 300zx twin-turbo you know
these were modern cars with with
turbochargers and
you know all this new cool [ __ ] and here
was just sort of almost 911s really
still sort of the same since the 60s you
know and so that kind of dragged on but
to revisit those cars now the fact that
they were unchanged from the 60s to the
mid 90s isn't it is a positive it's an
endearing quality it's it's it's such a
um they developed that body and chassis
so thoroughly over those 30 years that
it's such a finely engineered thing that
you can take it and build something like
a singer out of it a singer 911 it is as
like I remember of their regular car
right is as fast around Laguna Seca as a
Ferrari four or five eight with no
traction control and manually
thing yeah yeah yeah I mean they've done
wonders with those chasse's and they've
really lightened them with carbon bodies
and and so it is possible to take that
chassis further it just would have cost
Porsche Porsche lost so much money in
the 90 student Porsche was really
hanging on by a thread and they were
losing money like crazy until Volkswagen
avid group came in and that's where you
ended up with the water-cooled cars the
Boxster and then the Cayenne but in the
90s when they were doing the 99 3s from
ignite they were losing crazy amount of
money on those cars Whelan yeah yeah
it's a weird car right it's like they
stuck with that crazy design for so long
yeah it feels it feels old it feels like
25 years older than it really is
and yet it is so finely made yeah so
interesting right so with strange
combinations as opposed to something
like that's our that's a 993 gt2 RS
let's move don't I for you to phone yeah
that's very nice that's a beautiful car
so you know if you look at the passenger
compartment the roof line the windshield
the side window to this car you know
that's basically unchanged from the 70s
to the late nineties it's such a pretty
shape mm-hmm it's just like some shape
that people just gravitate towards and
it's usually the really old ones
you're something about an old one when
you see him in person like if you see
I've really nicely done like 71 long
nose yeah there's something about them
you like so much so light you know they
they have the kind of Airy about them I
just I think you know of all the classic
cars they are the most usable you know
to just run around the city and drive
you know you can drive a car from the
70s you know Magnus [ __ ] drives that
car oh you know yeah cars in the
seventies like no problem you could do
that dude Magnus had this car that he
sold some rock and roll star huh in
England he had this silver with blue
stripes and it was like a 69 I think I
remember that car yeah oh my god that
car was a magic getting he's got he's
got cool taste there's a video of him
like driving it going around this corner
you know that he had that video that
they made about him yeah a little short
document outlaw that document
and he comes around in this old-school
silver portion you look at he like yeah
that's a whole different thing he's
doing than everybody else and he's not
even driving fast like you don't even
have to drive fast that thing it weighs
what is it weigh
I mean 2500 pounds it's so like baby and
it doesn't have a lot of power yeah well
one of the things I love about my car is
with the lift on it and the tires
you've got like less grip than a normal
911 so if nobody's around like I can
slide entrance ramps like I can be a
silly bastard in in that car and it's
it's just extra fun look at this oh yeah
it is the silver car with the blue yeah
that's cool yeah even when you hear the
engine it doesn't sound like anything
else it's a weird little mechanical
creature yeah cuz of a small
displacement that's probably a 2 or a 2
or a 2 - you know it's not like this big
bore 38 like you've got you know I've
got a 3-2 which is a bit more of a bass
II kind of tone yeah the older higher
it's like really those ones are so 60s
wonder little yeah damn there's no
pretty big inside like it's the same
size inside as your car like you could
get in it and drive it and it's like
even those 356 is the really old
Porsches in the 50s like those are
actually kind of roomy like when you put
that engine in the back get your feet
can go pretty far forward yeah and the
Germans are pretty big people - yeah one
of the things with Porsche specifically
is about tall people fit now they got
barbarian DNA men right and the CEO for
sure for a very long time was six four
and so that he demanded
that's why Panamera looks like it does
so that a six foot four person can fit
in the back it's exactly that reason
oh wow yeah what they do with the
backseat of 911 so those are ridiculous
are for kids yeah I don't
I think that's an insurance thing I
think by being a four-seater yeah I just
don't have rear seats no I mean you
could have a friend get in the back of
your 911 for a couple of blocks yeah
yeah it's possible but it's more like
you just you know you throw your duffel
bag back there or whatever this is just
too tight it's too tight but the ones
you buy don't have rear seats so what do
you care you buy the RS is they don't
have the rear seats well when if I Drive
like one of those cars especially the
older ones like
you know at the 964 huh I'd like the
most stripped-down yeah that's what I
like yeah yeah it makes sense the malt
like I don't want a radio I don't want I
like a radio I don't want
air-conditioning nothing I use my car
every day and so I have a radio
conditioning but yeah I know you mean
but a car like that yeah like a little
ride yeah it's like you're taking a ride
more than it is like you're driving no
driving is the thing yeah that's what
you're doing you're driving yeah that's
my Lamborghini I treat like that when I
when I I don't take that to do [ __ ]
when I go out and drive that car like
that is my activity yeah so like you got
like magnets he's experiencing you know
what a normal person experience is when
they're enjoying the pleasure of driving
but he's getting they way more an analog
way more super like car if it's all
ancient [ __ ] tech those like cars are
real easy to drive though and you've got
a little engine you could give a light
clutch you can have a light shifter you
don't need you know the more power
you've got the heavier duty everything
needs to be and so when you dial that
stuff back in the cars 2,000 pounds and
the engines only 200 horsepower you can
just fingertip the whole thing it's very
easy yeah my friend Todd said this to me
is a very wise thing so it doesn't
matter how fast you're going just matter
how fast it feels totally he was talking
about like old nine eleven thousand
percent a thousand percent it's wise
wise like it's a wise perspective
because you go yeah have you just
enjoying the car like you're supposed to
get maximum enjoyment like it doesn't
have to be attached to a number correct
like if you didn't know how fast we were
going you weren't looking at your car
other than for the purposes of safety
yeah yeah you weren't like it wasn't a
dick contest there'd be a certain level
you wouldn't want to drive at I believe
in knowing the speeds like for me
personally yeah like my my cars have
fairly low low power like they're not
crazy huge power cars like and I think
beyond a certain point I just can't use
it anymore and so I think there's an
argument for having something like a
Tesla for every day and then having an
engaging machine for the weekends
[Applause]